was machst du denn hier bin ich ein
bisschen vor voll
oh nein alarmstufe rot meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich begrüße
sie herzlich zu einem neuen video auf
einem kanal und damit auch zeitgleich
zum ersten video einer neuen serie mit
dem namen was wäre eine beleidigung auf
einmal realität werden die grundlage für
die erste folge dieser neuen serie
bietet die hilf mir folge mein kumpel
knallt meine mutter und sie ist in ihn
verliebt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren die frage ist also heute was
würde passieren wenn die beleidigung ich
keine mutter du so ein real wäre ich
will sie gar nicht länger auf die folter
spannen wir fangen an
[Musik]
also soll er in neuss leiter dieser
titel uns dafür müsste man eigentlich
als vernünftiger mensch müsste man für
diesen titel
und für dieses video ideenkonzept
strafanzeige gegen rtl 2 stellen
jetzt bin ich ganz ehrlich mit euch das
kann man das kann man eigentlich als
zuschauer nicht mehr tolerieren dass
solche videos produziert werden
[Musik]
anschauen also new york also ich finde
das mit der anzeige wird so langsam eine
realistische option auf der couch
zusammen auf der schlafcouch so weit
will ja also ich glaube das ist wirklich
so dass ehrenloge was einem im leben
passieren kann
ja ich kann mir wirklich nichts unsere
vorstellung stelle ich stelle euch mal
vor kanal und ihr müsst in der schule
einen vortrag halten vor der ganzen
schule steht oben auf dieser bühne und
als also die ersten sätze spricht merkt
ihr das beim bühne hoch gehen euch hose
und unterhose gerissen ist okay stellt
euch das vor veränderlich das und selbst
dann hat euch das leben nicht so sehr
haupt genommen wie in diesem fall hier
jetzt darf man nicht okay ja ok bro
ehemals brauch ich habe ja aber ich muss
jetzt wirklich los zur arbeit okay geben
mir bitte nicht auf du sagt mit wo meine
familie meine eltern sind verheiratet
mal was mein vater sagen natürlich nicht
ok ich muss zur arbeit
sollte man wirklich nicht mehr spielen
dürfen ist einfach das ehren los ist was
es gibt da wird in dieser story leute
hat diese frau sogar ein mann ok und der
junge hier jonas hat sogar ein einfacher
die die sind funktionierende familie sie
wurden zusammen ja und dann wird etwa
die beleidigung real
wisst ihr was das schlimmste ist dass
wir nicht mehr die kuscheltiere hier
umgedreht haben die mussten einfach die
ganze zeit zu schauen hat einer die luft
jetzt raus gelassen weil da wir uns
bereit
ganz ehrlich da kann man nicht die folge
schon beenden da habe ich wirklich schon
genug leute sowas sollte nicht halb im
spass nicht mal zur provokation von rtl2
durchgespielt werden okay so was will
ich nicht seht des erlöses geht niemand
sollte jemals in seinem leben in die
situation kommen okay niemand hat jemals
in die situation kommt dass ein anderer
junge in seinem alter zu ihm sagen kann
du weißt du was ich habe deine mutter
und es ist einfach die wahrheit ist dass
es gibt dazu einen sehr kräftigen
kommentar von christina wenn das mir
passiert wäre
liga ich hätte jugendamt gerufen und
mich selbst zur adoption frei gegeben
welche option bleiben die noch als
junger mann im 21 jahrhundert heutzutage
jeder mensch sagt zu die a-liga ich mach
das hat deine mutter ist macht das mit
aller macht das schlimm genug wenn es
dann wirklich erwartet das leben vorbei
einfach nur casper kann man die kann man
nichts anderes zu sagen wollte kaspar
oder auch wie jan von gewitter im kopf
neuerdings sagt kachler was soll ich
dazu sagen wie viel genau so die worte
wir euch das kann es kann doch nicht die
nicht mal im spaß nicht mal im spaß geht
so was das wirklich ein einmaliger fehlt
das ein einmaliger ausrutscher und du
weißt auch papa ist so viel weg jetzt
wird noch mehr heran als eigentlich
vorher schon jetzt fängt sie auch noch
anders zu rechtfertigen also so ganz
ehrlich und das jahr spielte ich mal
nicht so auf ok ja gut so hast zwar
gesehen was in diesem moment gerade
passiert
übrigens da hin weil ich hab's gesehen
das war die beste leben er sagt zu
seiner mutter eltinger mama kommst du
überhaupt noch klar in seiner existenz
du hast an meinem kumpel gevögelt und
sie sagt so aber dein vater ist manchmal
lange weggeschaut vergessen warum greift
die ganze zeit nicht da ist papa
arbeitet damit weder schulden bezahlen
können als dankeschön dafür lernt dass
du mit meinem kumpel in jeder legst du
dann zusammen oder was würde ganzen
landes der welt aber sie sind ja auf der
couch gelegt also man darf diese aber
muss auch bei der bahn bleiben leute
wenn leute auf der couch gelernt und
sind davon nicht sagen dass die bett
gelandet sind
bei allem verständnis für petra und ihre
sehnsucht danach sich als frau wieder
toll zu finden muss man ganz klar sagen
caspar man muss an dieser stelle sagen
ganz klar casper wahlweise auch carlo
wie gesagt je nachdem was einem gerade
geeignet erscheint in die situation also
da kann man gar kann man nicht drüber
reden leute ist das allerletzte ist dann
auch noch so druck auf den eigenen sohn
ausgeübt der gerade mitbekommen hat
wieso vor seinen augen so seine familie
zerbricht sondern zu sagen jetzt machen
wir nichts von diesen fast aus okay wir
waren nicht im bett wir waren nur auf
der schlafcouch so was ist mir echt noch
nie passiert und dann noch zu hause aber
auf dem weinfest mit ramon ich habe mich
so gut gefühlt ich hab so gelacht
liga einfach kopfschuss einfach einen
kopfschuss bei sowas das geht überhaupt
nicht so was ist mir noch nie passiert
ach nee in not steht das noch nie da die
komplette familie und deinen ehemann
betrogen
es ist nicht so als wäre das eine
entschuldigung das ist mir noch nie
passiert ist es sollte überhaupt nie
passiert und dann ja aber ich habe ja
schon eine gute zeit auf den beiden fest
ach so na dann
dann mache oder ich weiß dass da alles
überhaupt nicht sein ja weil ich meine
du bist echt 20 jahre jünger er ist mein
freund mein job wir dürfen ihnen aber
auch nicht aus der verantwortung heraus
nehmen leute also schlimm genug deswegen
so deswegen sollte sowas auch nicht
passieren deswegen passiert sowas auch
so selten also eine beleidigung wird
tatsächlich sehr selten war weil
einerseits brauchst du dafür dem tat
motorrad her komplett geistig am ende
sein muss menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend auf jedem level und
gleichermaßen aber auch einen freund der
suchtkranke 31 ist dass er also dass
diese zwei parts so zusammenkommen das
ist gott sei dank extrem selten aber man
muss eben auch betonen dass der kumpel
in so einer situation ganz schwer mit
schuldig ist
ja ihr könnt ihr also rein vom alter her
auch mein sohn sein aber nein kein aber
cicek was du gesagt hast und lass es
okay dass an dem punkt gibt kein aber
wer denkt sich jetzt gerade ticker es
kann es kann doch nicht wahr sein mein
kumpel hat wirklich was mit meiner
mutter am laufen war was ist was ist
wenn die ganzen leute die mir im
internet immer gesagt haben dass sie mit
meiner mutter was was es für die recht
hatten gut
der papagei erstmal schön dass du da
bist der ramon den kennst du ja du papa
ist es irgendwie ganz ganz komische
sache passiert und zwar ramon hat deine
frau hat ihr auf dem schlafsofa
gesellschaft geleistet ich sag das jetzt
mal so und jetzt stellt sich für uns als
restliche familie noch die frage die wir
mit dir auch gerne klären wollten papa
wo verbuddeln wenn man mal eigentlich
sollte an der stelle müsste mich auch
entschuldigen ich muss zum bahnhof der
pole muss los zugpferd in wenigen
minuten ab ganz wichtig für euch jetzt
leute check hier einfach vorgeschlagen
dass wieder ab und abonniert hier meinen
kanal sonst fängt auch euer bester
kumpel was mit ihrer mutter an ich bin
mir der stadt heraus leute bleibt stabil